this news to u.s. stock markets will
start the day in a long-awaited
correction the Dow Jones Industrials
fell more than a thousand points
yesterday for the second time in a week
the Dow had its biggest ever one-day
point decline on Monday the index is
down more than 10% from an all-time high
of more than 26,000 two weeks ago
Kenneth Rogoff is a former chief
economist at the International Monetary
Fund he's now a professor of economics
and public policy at Harvard good
morning I know you've said that what we
can recall happening is a recalibration
not a catastrophe how would you explain
this volatility well it's gone up really
fast like gangbusters for a while so
it's hard to get completely worked up
about the fact that's gone partway down
nobody quite knew why it went up so far
but I think the news is good the global
growth is very strong US growth is
strong profits or strong wages are up
but I think what investors are nervous
about is interest rates might start
going up and stocks have been the only
game in town you put your money in bonds
you got nothing and now some money will
shift out and housing mortgages will be
more expensive so that that's I think
the fear in Washington this week there
was another debate about spending Rand
Paul kept them everybody there late last
night talking about the debt and deficit
is there gonna be any connection between
that and these big numbers we're hearing
and possible interest rates going up
that might hurt the economy you know it
could come down the road so we could see
pressure on the Federal Reserve not to
raise interest rates because it's
painful for the stock market it's
painful for the US government so far
that's not what's going on here I mean
let's face it it's been sort of a circus
in Washington for a year and the stock
market just goes up and up so to say
that it's craziness in Washington that's
driving the stock market down kind of
hard case to make you know I think it's
really a good news story that but the
fear that interest rates will go up and
maybe stocks aren't the only game in
town you say it's a good news story but
a lot of people can still are very
worried and a little freaked out to use
a technical term so what attributes do
you think investors really need right
now during this time so so it's really
hard around the stock market is when
it's gone
going up you want to say I'm missing the
boat I shouldn't mortgage my house I
should put everything in and then when
it's going down you go oh my gosh I've
got pull everything out and the small
investor most of us just get creamed by
this it's hard to second-guess things if
everyone knew the stock market was going
down another ten percent it would drop
like a rock today but maybe it'll go
back up so it's very hard advice to
follow but to try to stay calm
sure look at your portfolio but maybe
not right now in the middle of the storm
the same time you point out the
fundamentals of the economy our good
corporate earnings are expected to be
anywhere between eight and ten percent
and continue all of that great what
about and this is following on Jon's
questions that the government will have
to bar about a trillion dollars who's
gonna buy that debt what countries well
for the moment everyone wants to buy US
debt the dollars King in a way it hasn't
been since the 1950s
now that could turn if global interest
rates go up and we don't really know why
they've come so low it'll get painful
politicians will have to do stuff they
don't seem very good at that so it could
go wrong but it's probably not something
that's happening overnight all right
thank you Ken thank you you're so calm
and steady I'd like to know when you
start freaking out Ken be there when
that happens yeah thank you very much
thank you